We will use classes to build this movie website. Let
us begin, by recalling what we already know about classes.
Remember the blueprint analogy? Previously, we had compared a blueprint,
to a class. We had said that a blueprint of
a building, contains information about the building. Like the number
of rooms in the building. The height and the weight
of the walls. Now, we can use one blueprint to
build several buildings. And these buildings we call instances or
examples of that blueprint. Classes are like a
blueprint. Now we've seen previously that a class
like Turtle, contains information about what a Turtle
can do. For instance, move forward, turn right. And
we use that information to create multiple examples
or instances of that class. We call them Brad
and Angie that drew different shapes. In the
same way, we now want to create a class
called Movie, which will allow us to create
multiple instances of itself, instances like Toy Story and
Avatar. So then the next big question in front
of us is. What data should this class Movie
contain? Now I'm going to present a list of
data points for you, that you can consider. Here
they are. Which one of the following do you
think the class movie, should remember for each movie?
Check all of the boxes that you think the class Movie should remember.